welcome to grantchester finally you are
here you are the youngest participant
and it's your first time are you looking
forward for this event yeah
uh grandchester is one of the most
prestigious events inches and making my
debut is really special for sure
and also it's special
remember actually about the existence of
grantchester when did you start to
follow the events of grantchester do you
remember any specific event
um
I think I started like
a few years back I don't remember
exactly but uh yeah I do follow all the
all the events and
especially since like granchester has
like most of the top 10 players so many
strong players it's
it's of course a nice event to follow
and
um I mean especially in Zagreb there was
a very nice event which Magnus dominated
in 2019. that remember that event I
remember quite quite well yeah that's
great and also also event is very
special also because vishana displayed
here right and you're going to play
together in the same tournament
um have it ever happened before and what
are you thinking about it the fact that
you played together with vision yeah of
course we've interacted a lot we've
trained together we've played some
training games but uh this is going to
be my first time in a tournament game
actually and yeah I can't be more
excited for it yes I mean three games
with me yeah where you're dreaming about
it before
I mean at the start I couldn't even
dream about it but but
yeah I like uh
I've always wanted to play play them in
a tournament game and
I have an opportunity here and this is
there's going to be like
um a lot of fun and uh
yeah hopefully we'll play some very nice
games yeah we'll hope so too for sure
and I was also wondering what was your
preparation the preparational routine
over this years I know that you were not
using for some favorite computers I mean
how new technologies affected your
preparation and do you use it now right
now
yeah till the pandemic started I have I
wasn't really working with computers but
after that I'm
working with computers regularly and
I mostly use them for openings and like
I mean preparation for this uh for this
tournament it's been just a
um some openings and puzzles and Playing
Games
Etc
and my last question you know in this
event and many others from the young age
you have to play against really strong
opponents higher rated and you know many
kids many young players they have this
fear to play with high rated stronger
opponents how do you fight with those
fears I mean what what do you tell to
yourself I mean how do you go through
all this
I guess I'm I'm experienced enough not
to like fear stronger opponents I mean I
I used to do that when I was very young
but
I guess I've gotten used to it now what
how do you get this self-confidence
I guess once you start beating opponents
beating uh higher returns it's uh
it's just uh I guess it's just
experience yeah yeah that's great I mean
just start beating them
so thank you so much and really
appreciate your answers and all the best
of luck in your first GCT event yeah
thank you
[Music]
foreign